such a situation because I thought for
sure I was gonna feel one way I think
initially I was like how dare Sony not
give and then I thought about everything
else hmm
okay way but there is two sides to every
story yeah no this is like when you hear
like a friends of yours broke up who you
know both the boyfriend and girlfriend
realize I do like but I haven't talked
with any of them directly I'm just
hearing rumors about what go go who's my
friend it feels like hello there reject
nation i'm greg alba um when do you
leave Amy we go when do you leave with
us today back on the channel Wendy you
could go check out her YouTube channel
the movie couple channel oh she does
with her hubby dusty as I like to say
does anyone say that
hubby dusty oh I should that's cute
right hubby dusty dusty Hugh they do
reaction videos as well they're
fantastic one of my favorite couples in
the world hey hey have you seen new rock
stars before new rocks yeah my favorite
channels I love these guys think they're
brilliant some spider-man news is broken
out recently I'm sure you've heard about
it since you work at Collider we did a
livestream immediately after we heard
the news and I had some pretty strong
opinions even while I was out weighing
both sides since I did that livestream
some of my opinions have slightly
shifted some of them have just been more
amplified I'll talk more about it
afterwards as I feel like for anyone to
get to get a good breakdown from anyone
so it's gonna be new Rockstar if you
haven't seen their channel before go
subscribing them right away let's see
what they got to say all right and then
we'll give our opinions about it so stay
tuned after the reaction welcome back to
new rockstars I'm Erik Bosse in
spider-man's days in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe maybe sadly over
[Music]
[Laughter]
breaking down between Sony the studio
that owns the film rights of spider-man
and Disney's Marvel Studios
Kenneth II's wonderful dream world that
we all called MCU since 2015 Marvel and
Sony have shared the rights to
spider-man but that deal has according
to sources ended and
I mean we no longer get to see
spider-man appear in future MCU films
and that MCU characters no longer appear
in future spider-man movies yeah again
this could dramatically change the
future of superhero movies as we know
them and why maybe just maybe all might
not be lost
okay so here's what went down back in
2015 Marvel and Sony announced a deal to
co-produced spider-man after suni who
had owned the rights to spider-man for
decades decided to shift directions from
the two underperforming amazing
spider-man films with Andrew Garfield
piano was marvel studios is Sony no or
spider-man to it Sony got to make
spider-man movies with Marvel characters
like Tony Stark Nick Fury and Cu events
like the blip happy Parker in their big
crossover events civil war than any war
and gore keeping the tonality and
interconnectivity in balance as all
things should be the plan was to extend
this sharing deal by two more films
presumably a spider-man 3 and maybe
another MCU crossover event so what
changed well the deadline during
negotiations between Disney and Sony
which and other Sony countries at Disney
wanted to code distribute that the
studio's co-financed them fifty-fifty
and that will mean the studio's would
also split the profits from these films
right down the middle
essentially Kevin Feige and the Disney
Marvel team wanted more influence over
Sony's properties and to reap more
reward for that influence we'll keep
helping you make Spidey but you gotta
pay up for it I got new mats to buy but
Sony according to sources flat-out
refuse that offer and talks broke down
why well spider-man far from home just
became Sony's most profitable film most
passionate 1.1 million dollars in the
box office and due to general greed you
can imagine them not wanting to share a
dime of any future billions and it looks
as though Sony is betting that the
recent success of these spider-man
character has perhaps less to do with
vikas magic touch and the
interconnectivity to the MCU
far from home spoiler warning for that
movie they're in the form of some Iron
Man heroes X star industry employees
happy Hogan Nick Fury Maria Hill and
Scrolls instead perhaps Sony is looking
at elements like Mysterio returning Jay
jonah Jameson and the groundwork that
they've already done to introduce these
sinister six themselves maybe we don't
maybe MCU connection to make a good
spider-man 3 movie oh my he wouldn't
rather share
now I take issue with that but based on
the tremendous success of a movie like
spider-man into the spider-verse which
won an Oscar really enjoyed the
collaboration between Sony and Marvel
that has given us Tom Hollands Peter
Parker now I'm not sure how much Kevin
Feige and the Marvel team were directly
responsible for everything we liked
about this version of the character it's
possible that John Watson Tom Holland
could produce another great Spider Man
sequel without Marvel's help but over
these passes also forged chemistry with
a number of M su mainstays after strange
to the guardians of the galaxy Falcon
and Winter Soldier
Rudy ant-man Captain Marvel Nick Fury
well his scroll and posture but still
Jackson future possible team ups with
characters like the Hulk Thor in future
it's you additions like blade the
fantastic green mana mutants maybe
someday daredevil leave a torch in
Deadpool see fans if I do understand
that it's me promise of spider-man
nearly existing in this universe it's
like you know exactly well well we
should react the way we would react and
know just the right movie reference to
take your business so nice for Marvel
heroes and it drowns it in sin by oh you
made a breakup totally sucks
happy really needs this his name is not
reflect its emotional state
you could say they'd probably release
for this explaining why Spiderman wasn't
included in Feige space for lineup but
it was faithful yeah I guess we were
lucky to get him in the MC as long as we
had we're grateful but you know now it's
kind of like the awesome dude that we've
been hanging out with is being told that
he can with us anymore because his
parents don't like our parents and we
know what is with us but guys guys this
isn't over
sources are saying negotiations are
still under way it's a public
negotiation really power play by one of
the sides great publicly bring the other
side back to the table but here's what's
really being willing to walk away from
our goal tells us about their priorities
for future spider-man films I do not
think this means that Tom Holland is
automatically done playing spider-man
like tomatoes in the type of movie folks
the actors and crew of that movie signed
a deal with Sony not Disney so it's
possible that the studio of the director
the other key players could put together
a Sony produce spider-man 3 that
everyone's happy with and it could
happen it's also possible that this
increases the likelihood of a venom
sequel with Tom Hollands spider-man
whatever you feel about the Tom Hardy
film if this were to happen it would
require a great deal of tonal
adjustments like essentially Sony would
have to do with Tom Hardy's venom what
Marvel did with Thor and Ragnarok like
transform him from a movie loner to
funnier team player another option would
be to billion successive into the
spider-verse yes in spider people like
Miles Morales for Glenn stasis or the
whole Deadpool they gotta be counting on
their abilities these fans with other
beloved names from the comics but really
the most likely option just seems to be
a spider-man 3 that deals directly with
the aftermath of the part from home
ignore any of the ties to the MCU from
homecoming or far from home like Peter
would have to off-screen sever all of
his connections to Tony Stark probably
toss out Edith and all this uniquely
stark tech and then like web all over
all the spider-man murals and then force
and made a breakup was happening Monica
all the familiar faces return plus J
jonah Jameson and a sinister six they
need a lot of fans wouldn't mind I mean
we would roll her and we remember how
great things were in the past yeah don't
be a little eight-year-old who's gonna
buy all the toys
essentially Sonia is like Panos
telling vibey I will shred your universe
down to its last atom and then with the
work you've done for me create my own
grateful universe that doesn't remember
your old one yeah no wonder Sony doesn't
want spider-man and Thanos in the same
sentence do you think there's a future
for Tom Hollands seems like he was
really thinking so he's the enemy
because I've heard we're here for each
other right follow me unser commit to it
already Ava subscribe to new rock sirs
for more updates as something changed
about the situation in the forum you and
thank you for joining me and I just
wanna be there when happy gets dumped I
guess it's just gonna be alone with
Tony's claw robot because it's not the
worst way to spend a Friday night guys
video make sure to subscribe in them
it's funny because I mean I've heard
some other people talk recently seems
like the fan outcry has been a little
bit more towards blaming Sony I'm really
at the point where I'm like I don't
think a hundred percent of blame goes to
either department no no this is Beth Lee
I'm both of the companies right now it's
just and usually I'm hearing industry
people talk that article it's more like
Disney's one being greedy and dizzy this
but this seemed like he was pretty upset
with Sony here yeah I'm not gonna lie
I've been pretty heartbroken
today it was weird I went to the gym
this morning what's the gym pump some
iron is that the gym and I found myself
kind of in this weird down mood and I
was just sort of reflecting doing some
self introspect while that was working
on my glutes and I realized whoa I'm
really like affected by this it was kind
of strange I've never had movie news hit
me so hard and while there's still the
possibility of they can make this worth
everyone's biggest guess is that this is
a lot of public negotiation using the
press using fandom to kind of help get
either have that party win some way
right what bummed me out was this as I
was thinking about some stuff I've heard
the argument brought up I think yeah
okay if let's say spider-man no longer
with the MCU I figure we could get some
things from spider-man 3 that I wouldn't
mind it's something that is not so MCU
heavily tied none of this Tony Stark
shadow I didn't mind them it would be
something where it is strictly Peter
Parker spider
am base which i think would be cool to
just get that even if it was still with
the MCU and they did a spider-man 3 and
it was only that I'd be pretty happy
with that I feel like that's something a
lot of fans have wanted and you can even
deal with the death of Uncle Ben in some
way you don't have to show it but you
can actually knowledge it and make us I
to me I feel like that's kind of been a
missing part of his character because
spider-man's DNA is so intrinsic
intrinsically tied intrigue goddamn you
know it's ours it's tied to his
motivation for why he's a superhero
right as opposed to like homecoming
which was about that idea sounded cool
than me but then I thought about okay
what about after spider-man 3 yeah well
really started making me sad was the
thought that he could not appear in any
Avengers movies that's it that's what
bummed me out there's a lot of people
who have been defending the the choice
of Sony just taking spider-man in and
just making it only spider on me so I'm
like yeah that sounds cool but you're
completely eliminating the possibility
now of spider-man being able to
crossover with the Avengers and that
shit's awesome that's that's so great
what I was thinking about was the the
Tom Holland portrayal specifically you
know you're an actress when you create a
character you have to create this
backstory in history in the world this
character lives in what do you do with
that now it's like are you gonna reboot
the character in your head were you you
have to suddenly get rid of all the
things with having Tony Stark be your
mentor affect your life then the loss of
Tony star in the whole world of the
Avengers and the adventure against
Thanos and the blip all these things
like does what this mean that they can't
even acknowledge those things that's
what it sounds like what everyone's been
saying yes that they can't even say blip
they can't even the reference to lines -
I think that storyline I lost them see
you so it depends on what deal they may
be and eventually end up with if they
still can't come to terms then maybe you
know you kind of beg borrow and steal a
little bit of like can we use this part
of the MCU it's kind of like when Fox
have x-men we couldn't use that with the
word mutant
Yeah right you're gonna run into a
problem with that and Afra comic fans
little things like that means so much
now Tom Hollands Peter Parker has been
in multiple MCU movies all of his
standalone movies have also had MC
touch so that's gonna be really hard for
fans to kind of dissociate that and it's
gonna be so noticeable because of how
the whole situation went down it's kind
of crazy how public this news has become
and it does seem like public negotiation
hey Wendy what is uh Sony's tweets over
here because I notice new rock stars in
to go over this can you read that for me
much of today's news about spider-man
has mischaracterized recent discussions
about Kevin Feige involved in the
franchise we are disappointed but
respect Disney's decision not to have
him continue as a lead producer of our
next live-action spider-man film we hope
this might change in the future but
understand the many new responsibilities
that Disney has giving him including all
of their newly added Marvel properties
do not allow him time sorry do not allow
him
damn it Wendy do not allow time for him
to work on IP they do not own kevin is
terrific and we are grateful for his
help and guidance and appreciate the
path he has helped put us on which we
will continue it's a nice statement it's
a nice nod to Kevin Feige of like he did
put in the work the thing that I enjoy
about Kevin Feige is he gets the comics
and I think he gets kind of what he
wants to give the fans and what the fans
were crazy about you know and that's why
he puts together the team these
producers and these and these directors
it works but do you know what I find
very odd about when I first read this
statement hmm I thought it was weird
that Disney didn't say anything about
Kevin Feige
the statement specifically goes out of
its way to say for him to work on Marvel
properties that he does not own like
they're specifying they do not they do
not own those yet they're talking about
Kevin Feige Spurs company that is not
them they're talking about a birth do
you I do what I mean Sony Pictures is
putting out a statement about Kevin
Feige who's not one of their people
right and they're like being the
spokesperson for Kevin Feige why okay my
flag is no long I wonder if there's some
sort of outcry that we missed about like
oh well Kevin made this happen and he's
the one so they're kind of like it's not
just him I kind of understand the the
part where says like do not allow time
for him to work on IP they do not own I
mean if he works for Marvel technically
can't work for you you're a full-time
employee you can't just go and work for
some other people's IP well even though
you've you've started it in the
beginning because the deal was different
so technically personal feelings aside I
I kind of understand why they said this
I mean no I get why they said it I just
thought I just found it interesting that
they were that they were speaking for a
cabin if I D because I feel like Disney
should say so
well you see the thing is when we did
the livestream this statement had to
come out and then this day we come out
with a Steve I mean not from the time of
us filming this it has something hasn't
come in so I don't know maybe they will
I feel like they should know it's in
their best interest for them to solve
this the whole thing about the 50% thing
of how that's too much to ask for and
I'm like all right maybe Disney gets
like 20 to 40% somewhere in there right
one thing I did not think about when I
was doing the livestream was how I think
Disney gets all money for merchandising
I didn't think about that which is a big
deal like yeah of that I'm like a chunk
of money that there's a big wrench in
the whole like screw you Sony when I'm
like oh wait a minute yeah Sony probably
deserves some money from that don't they
since they own spider-man like they
should probably get some chunk you feel
like that asked for the 50% a little
steep huh I personally didn't when I was
just thinking about the film considering
how it is the the last two spider-man
movie like people are talking about
Spider versus Graham I'm like that's a
totally different animated movie it's
Miles Morales LED it's amazing it's an
incredible film but oscar-winning what
are we different
and yes so so is venom which is not even
venom accurate for a lot of it you know
like they're getting a whole new
director and cinematographer for that
one you know like they they know that
even though it was a big hit that there
are some flaws of that movie I was think
about the movies I was like well the
spider-man world seems to benefit so
much for being an MCU involved and yet
far from home felt so tied to MCU lerner
dealing so much with post post blip post
Thanos the loss of Tony Stark it was
considered the end of the phase who
Mysterio is and where he came from his
hide exactly way deep they like rooted
themselves yeah so I'm like well that
that seems like it should be a 50/50
split on the movies but if you're not
gonna go 50/50 after you've had a deal
for 5% of of just a small 5% before
Disney had 5% I think of like opening
day sales they deserve more money
I guess 50% is a lot to ask for
you'll 5% is a little but they get 100%
of the merchandise this is true so yeah
it's all [ __ ] it's all tricky I feel
like they'll solve it I worry for Tom
Holland my god if we get another
spider-man reboot with a different ice
words they won't do that no faith in the
project at home into like spider-verse
or something like that make probably
bring that live-action to life to me
this statement seemed like to try to
point it all at he's too busy Kevin
Feige to lead produced this I feel like
if he was getting paid what he did what
he feels he should hate it would it be
too busy you know this OPR so yeah
exactly yeah can you take it take it
with what it was a grain of salt if you
will I think it is nice that they put
they did put out a statement yeah no
nice gesture it makes them look good all
right guys well either way new rock
stars thanks for putting this video
together was more insightful than before
thank you Andy for being here to go
check out her YouTube channel guys you
can subscribe the real rejects click
that notification bell you can check us
out
patron our do weekly q and A's TV show
reaction stream along several shows
reaction highlights included and oh
let's give a patron of the deja to man
named Brandon M you're gonna like this
guy he's from Australia
he's 18 so he's just legal so if you
want to have an affair cheat on hubby
dusty Brandon hubby dusty with an Aussie
yeah thanks Andy
let's hope Dustin doesn't watch this
video he's talked about like he wants to
save up enough money come down to LA
which means shouldn't have to go on a
date with him Wendy that's what we've
said up here today Brad this one blocks
me from it no well well we have ways of
working around I think Dustin might get
a little bit excited at the thought of
this he's looking to spice up the
marriage I speak for them
I know how to make keep marriages alive
you know I'm telling you going on a date
with one of our patrons will benefit
both of us
he'll increase is pledge and I'm gonna
get a 50/50 how did you will get an
experience we're done here